-Welcome back, everybody.
We're talking with
one of my favorites,
Liam Neeson, right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He stars in the new film,
"Blacklight."
Let's talk about "Blacklight."
This is written
by Mark Williams.
-Mark Williams.
-Yeah.
-Go ahead. Uh-huh.
-What are you reaching for?
I'm going to get spot out here.
-Rather than me go,
"What is the film about?"
Uh, well, it is about me
doing a -- okay.
Here it is.
-[ Laughs ]
You came prepared, yeah.
-"Blacklight" --
-You're not even off-script.
-Do you mind me doing this?
-No, I don't mind.
-"Blacklight" offers the kind of
high-octane thrills
people associate
with Liam Neeson,
uniquely combined with a mature,
political edge.
[ Audience oohs ]
This is very much a film
about uncovering
corruption at the highest levels
of government power
and the decision to stop blindly
following
corrupt leaders while
reexamining
one's set of inner morals."
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next time you come on,
I would like you
to just read the phone book.
It still would sound amazing.
Yeah.
-And there's thrills and spills,
you know.
-Yeah, there's thrills
and spills, but this is --
the guy is behind "Ozark,"
which is one of the best shows.
-I love "Ozark."
-Ever. Are you caught up?
-I love it. Yes.
I can't -- Laura Linney
is a good friend of mine.
Ah, stuff it.
-[ Laughs ]
And I called her up,
I sent her a message saying,
"Laura, I'm finished,
series four, part one.
When is part two coming out?"
-You did that?
-Yeah.
-I didn't do that.
-And she said, "April."
And I thought,
"Okay, this is February."
And then I got in touch
with Mark Williams and I said,
"Mark, when is part two
coming out?"
And he says, "Oh, autumn,
the fall."
[ Laughter ]
-You go, "Hey, I thought we were
friends."
Yeah, I need this. I keep
stretching it out because I go,
"I don't want the show to end."
-I love it.
-Anyways, this movie's
everything you want.
It's pure entertainment.
It's Liam Neeson.
It's a popcorn movie.
It's awesome.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Liam Neeson, "Blacklight."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Based on the fact these crazies
are about to bury you
in a shallow grave,
something happened.
-I've been out here
almost two years
playing a part
with these racist bastards,
and it's getting inside my head.
I got sloppy.
They found a few bugs.
They somehow traced it back
to me.
-Stop it,
Special Agent Davidson.
I need you to keep your wits
intact.
-i thought it was your job
to get me out of this kind of
situation.
-That is correct.
And I'm about to.
-That's exactly right!
Yes!
Liam Neeson, everybody.
"Blacklight" opens in theaters
February 11th.